[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle
pas j'avais 12 ans quand j'ai été
par mes parents on leur avait promis que
je ferai un apprentissage de couturier
mais en réalité j'ai été exploité
pendant plus d'un an comme vendeurs sur
le marché de cotonou je travaillais de
jour comme de nuit
je ne dormais jamais plus de quatre
heures d'affilée
les patrons étaient violents un jour
j'ai perdu une partie de l'argent de la
vente et ils m'ont frappé je m'appelle
françois j'avais 9 ans quand j'ai été
vendus par mes parents on leur avait
promis que je ferai un apprentissage
mais même ma mère n'y croyais pas c'est
mon père qui a finalement décidé
d'accepter l'argent des trafiquants
pendant plusieurs mois j'ai travaillé
comme domestique pour une famille qui
habitait en ville quand le père n'était
pas content de mon travail il me
frappait un jour je me suis bagarré avec
l'un des enfants de la maison quand le
père est rentré son fils lui a raconté
une autre dispute alors il m'a giflé
il m'a crié dessus il m'a dit que cette
nuit là je dormirai attaché à une corde
alors j'ai fui avant que la nuit tombe
je m'appelle clément j'avais 17 ans
quand j'ai rencontré françois et
valentin pour la toute première fois je
les ai interviewé dans le cadre de mon
travail de maturité sur le trafic et
l'exploitation d'enfants au bénin nous
nous connaissions à peine et pourtant
ils m'ont raconté leur histoire une
histoire qu'il n'avait jamais raconter à
qui que ce soit la honte d'avoir subi de
telles humiliations de ne pas être
devenu couturier ou électriciens comme
cela avait été promis à leurs parents
les empêchait de raconter leur passé il
m'a fallu des mois pour réaliser à quel
point ces interviews avait permis à
françois et valentin de se libérer qui
leur avait offert l'opportunité de
mettre des mots sur leurs souffrances
j'avais enregistré leur témoignage sur
une cassette une fois rentré à genève
j'ai donc commencé à les retranscrire
mais à ce moment le récit sont devenus
pour moi de plus en plus lourd cette
même parole qui leur avait permis de se
libérer d'un poids à présent m'accabler
je réécoutais les enregistrements au
point de connaître certains passages des
interviews par coeur mais je me sentais
toujours plus seul et démuni face aux
épreuves qu'ils avaient eu à surmonter
parmi tout ce qu'il m'avait raconté au
delà de la violence de leurs récits au
delà du sentiment de trahison qu'ils
éprouvaient à l'égard de leurs parents
ce qui me choque le plus c'est qu'il
n'avait jamais pu raconter leurs
histoires celles et ceux qui me sont
proches savent que j'ai toujours besoin
de parler quand je souffre se sentir
écouté ce savoir compris ça peut
paraître peu de chose mais c'est
tellement essentiel quand le poids de
nos remords se fait trop lourd je peux
difficilement décrire à quel point
j'étais triste en pensant que françois
et valentin n'avait pas eu cette chance
sachant que j'étais la première personne
à qui il s'était confié est conscient qu
à part ma professeure et qu'elle
commande de ma famille personne d'autre
ne lirai mon travail de maturité je me
sentais la responsabilité de partager
leurs témoignages
je leur ai donc fait cette promesse vos
voix seront entendues et j'ai commencé
par mes amis les plus proches pouvoir
raconter leur histoire me faisait me
sentir moins seul - seul certes mais
toujours aussi démunis j'ai alors
réalisé que cette promesse ne suffisait
pas que la responsabilité qui était la
mienne aller au delà de simplement
porter leurs voix pour être vraiment à
la hauteur de leur confiance
je me devais de faire plus je me devais
de faire une différence avec un groupe
d'amis du collège nous avons donc décidé
de créer une association
souvent on me demande pourquoi le bénin
pouvoir pourquoi avoir choisi cette
cause là
et je n'ai aucun doute je sais
parfaitement que françois et valentin
sont la réponse à cette question
c'est leur optimisme c'est leur courage
qui m'ont poussé à m'engager mais si
j'ai voulu vous parler ce soir sur le
thème beyond ce n'est pas pour répondre
à la question pourquoi mais plutôt
comment comment créer cette différence
pour moi s'engager c'est aller au delà
au delà de cette promesse est décidé
d'en faire plus s'engager c'est aller au
delà des limites qu'on croit être les
nôtres
j'avais 17 ans quand nous avons créé
notre association
je n'avais aucune expérience je n'avais
jamais participé à un projet de ce genre
mais j'ai décidé d'aller au delà de ce
sentiment d'impuissance s'engager c'est
également aller au delà de nos jugements
et ne nous idées préconçues je suis sûr
que la plupart d'entre vous quand vous
avez entendu les témoignages de françois
et valentin vous avez fait exactement
comme moi à l'époque vous ai dit mais
comment en parant peut-il faire ça son
enfant s'engager c'est essayer de se
mettre à leur place non pas pour trouver
une explication
encore moins une justification mais pour
pouvoir trouver la meilleure des
solutions
celle qui permettra de réellement créé
cette différence au début je jugeais
leurs parents j'étais en colère
encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je ne leur
pardonne pas d'avoir fait subir cela à
leur fils mais pour pouvoir venir en
aide aux jeunes j'ai été obligé de venir
en aide à leurs parents et pour ce faire
j'ai dû mettre de côté ce jeu ce
jugement
j'ai dû mettre de côté ma colère je
disais que s'engager c'est aller au delà
des limites c'est viser plus loin c'est
se fixer des objectifs qu'on ne pensais
pas être capable d'atteindre mais
s'engager c'est aussi parfois les
accepter ses limites les limites de
notre projet les limites de nos moyens
les limites de la différence qu'on
essaye de créer s'engager cet accès
et que tous nos efforts nous soit au
final qu'une simple goutte d'eau c'est
voir l'océan sans cesse se relever mais
décidé d'à nouveau tout donner pour une
nouvelle goutte d'eau cela fait bientôt
sept ans que j'ai rencontré françois et
valentin pour la toute première fois
j'ai tenu ma promesse
ce soir vous aussi vous avez entendu
leur voix il ya quelques minutes
vous aussi vous les avez rencontré
si l'on m'avait dit il ya sept ans que
je ferai un jour un tel taux que sur
cette aventure je n'y aurais jamais cru
et au fond quand je pense au chemin
parcouru je me dis que le moment qui a
été vraiment déterminant
ce n'est pas l'ouverture de l'école que
l'association a construite dans le
village de françois et valentin ce n'est
pas non plus la création de
l'association non le moment vraiment
déterminant celui où quelque chose a
changé c'est le moment je joue je
l'aurais fait la promesse de porter leur
voix car c'est à ce moment-là précis que
j'ai décidé d'aller au delà
au delà de la honte au delà de la
souffrance
au delà de l'impuissance faites-vous
cette promesse de faire une différence
je suis sûr que tout comme moi vous
serez surpris de voir où cette promesse
vous emmènera merci
[Applaudissements]